hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem weiteren
dollar video
allerdings schauen uns heute kein jahre
altes sommer rtl family stories video an
sondern meine damen und herren ihr seht
es bereits im titel eingeblendet heute
machen wir ein interview mit dominik
gregory und dafür fahren wir jetzt
erstmal nach leverkusen
ihr seht es vielleicht schon am
hintergrund gerade und der ein oder
andere große themen die story zuschauer
von damals kann sich eventuell auch an
diese kulisse schon erinnern sitze hier
nicht alleine sondern mit dominik danke
dass wir überhaupt tiere dürfen danke
dass wir überhaupt dieses video hier mit
ihr drehen dürfen ich blende euch jetzt
mal hier noch ein paar ausschnitte ein
von denen mit folgen von damals
also man hat schon gesehen dass die
frühere dome aus den folgen ein komplett
anderer mensch ist als die dominic rago
riesa immer wieder jetzt hier neben mir
sitzt also deswegen weil erst tragen
hier hat sich deine jetzige
lebenssituation auch gewicht situation
verändert ein anderer mensch nicht ein
highlight das buch ja doch mal auf den
folgen und dominik kann man hat auch
nicht wirklich vergleichen da war halt
wirklich eine rolle
die hat mir mega spaß gemacht in sachen
gemacht die man sonst eigentlich nicht
machen an der stelle muss man auch mal
ganz christ anmerken
du hast 95 kilogramm abgenommen war ganz
plötzlich wieder 83 kilo ist mehr
abgenommen als ich wirklich liegen
wie kam es dazu dann kam dieser punkt wo
du gesagt hast hey jetzt ist es sag ich
mal jetzt muss ich los wegen jahre vor
den sendungen
da habe ich aber nie wirklich geschafft
dort waren halt irgendwann auch einfach
so viel dass man sich kaum bewegen
konnte das heißt wirklich sport machen
oder so viel weg nur über ernährung das
funktioniert nicht auf dem land also ich
habe wirklich zahlreiche versuche
gestartet und wenn dann irgendwann
soweit ich gesagt habe okay dann muss da
jetzt eine hilfestellung her und habe
dann die vorbereitungen für einen bypass
op begonnen in der umstellung sport was
da alles dazugehört und hab dann gegen
magen bypass op buch innerhalb von zwei
jahren
jetzt noch mal in anlehnung an die erste
frage die ich ja gestellt hatte
dass die doppel in den früheren folgen
hat ein komplett anderer menschen
sondern nur jetzt halt dich komplett
verändert das video erwartet dass ihnen
folgen war es ja so den tagesablauf sah
so aus chips essen dann kamen die
marianne vorbei wie sieht denn jetzt so
ein typischer tag im leben der dominik
aus ich bin momentan in elternzeit ich
habe ja wir haben momentan bin ich in
elternzeit ich habe vor zehn monaten ihr
herz meine zweite tochter bekommen
ja das forum hat mich halt dann
natürlich versuche ich mich immer mehr
zu bewegen ist funktioniert der
mittlerweile andere gar denn
normalerweise bin ich ja noch im
berufsleben dazu vielleicht auch noch
mal eben kurz die zwischenfrage ist denn
deine ernährung enorm umgestellt worden
also sowas wie fleisch wurst salat gar
nicht mehr wirklich nur für die sendung
also klar von der ernährung habe die
sagen so viel habe ich gar nichts falsch
gemacht aber das war halt die menge
hatte gemacht sowie in den sendungen
dass ich so viel schokolade ich mag
eigentlich gar keine
und er hat sie verlassen darüber
gesprochen wir sind weil er so tipps
typen deswegen das mit schokolade dass
du dich das war wirklich genau hier den
blau hier starts pro jahr und da gab es
diese eine szene die ich euch mal kurz
ein
ihr habt jetzt fünf kartons ok 2012 da
merkt man erst mal dass das ganze sieben
jahre her dass jetzt mal die frage die
sich glaube ich auch jeder gestellt ich
habe auch ein bisschen mich vor dem
interview schlau gemacht was
interessiert wirklich die leute auch auf
instagram gefragt was die leute die ich
gerne fragen würden und was mir wirklich
auch mit am meisten sendet wurde ist wie
kam es überhaupt zu dem ganzen also
wieso hast du dich für die rolle
entschieden wissen wo auf eine
produktionsfirma zugegangen sind die auf
dich zugegangen wie kam es dazu das
wasser der hintergrund das war wirklich
total ungeplant ich war mit meiner
tochter also mit all ihren die in der
stadt und da hat
ich habe gesprochen habe ich mir nach
der brut und hält mir vorbei dann gucken
wir mal ob das was gibt und dann wurde
die gäste mitten im leben pulsiert das
war sogar mitten im leben vor dass man
sich direkt family stories war okay
jetzt mit mir leben und daraufhin kamen
dann die anfrage von rtl 2 für förmlich
durch kann mir genau vorstellen dass ihr
wahrscheinlich gedacht damals in der
innenstadt gekommen
drehen wir mal so kommt bestimmt das los
ich werde man hat ja nicht dass das so
ein nachklang hatte diese doppel ist ja
die figur schlechthin sage ich mal für
rtl glaub ich hab auch tatsächlich die
meisten family stories folgen wahrheit
wirklich ein paar just for fun jetzt war
eine ganz kurze frage die wir glaube ich
auch ganz kurz beantworten kannst
würdest du das ganze wiederholen
ja ich würde es wieder tun allerdings
nicht mehr unter den virus unter dem
namen und ohne mein kind da hätte ich
mich auch schon so gedacht dass du genau
so antworten wie er sei das ganze an
sich ist ja glaub ich mit erfahrung und
meine der ausschuss hat einen mega viel
spaß gemacht das ganze aber wenn man
halt einfach sagt man macht das noch mal
dann vielleicht mit einem anderen ziel
der anderen story ganz anders aufgebaut
und so weiter und so fort vielleicht
sieht er doch wenig später noch mal
irgendwann im fernsehen aber wir sagen
erst mal nicht erst eine frage die sich
auch ganz ganz ganz ganz viele leute
fragen wie lief so ein dreh überhaupt ab
was so dass ihr wirklich so eine riesige
skript vorher bekommen hat von wegen
du musst den satz sagen und dann kontert
marianne das und dann geht so weiter
oder war es wirklich hey wir kommen rum
und das ist die grobe idee und darum so
könnt ihr machen was wir wollen wenn der
ersten folge hatten wir tatsächlich so
versuchen regelbuch das haben wir bei
den nächsten folgenden ob man schnell
verworfen weil wir haben viel anders
gemacht haben hat einen leitfaden also
so ungefähr soll die teure aussehen das
soll passieren aber sonst war's halten
also es gab zwar die grobes rahmen
skript das wort gesagt hey das ist das
thema der folge
wir fahren dorthin um die uhrzeit haben
die technik dabei bleibe alles worum der
hat die folge sei auch von der
spontanität gelegt und es ist mir auch
in einigen fällen wirklich aufgefallen
dass du dann zwischendurch diese
doppelrolle selbst auch gar nicht
richtig ernst den konnte es auch einfach
losgelassen im schwimmbad in der
wasserrutsche oder auch
kinderspielparadies in dem autoscooter
da hat man halt wirklich gemerkt so ok
die schauspielerin dominik muss selbst
gerade über diese rolle doppel lachen in
so rutschig musste nicht wirklich
festhalten dann wirklich wirklich
stecken deiner benannt noch von hinten
jemand dann so das ist anstrengend
gewesen oben zu bleiben also du bist gar
nicht richtig steckengeblieben weil das
werk sehr sicher und direkt mit den
fragen wie film ist eigentlich echt vom
so einer folge im kinderparadies der
roller der beute einfach nicht kaputt
gehen mussten ansehen damit der kaputt
geht ja gesagt aber was macht dieser
rolle ist sind zwei teilnehmer wird
schon ordentlich die realität verdreht
sagen kann jetzt auch eine frage von wem
war das fake oder war das echt tante
marianne man könnte wenn man sich die
folgen anschauen wirklich denken es ist
eine richtige tanze weil ja auch leonie
da eine richtige tochter ist seit ihr
verwandt oder es ist einfach darauf die
schauspielerin die auch gecastet wurde
von rtl haben und wirklich beim ersten
dreh kennengelernt waren da hat auch
wirklich noch zaghaft und michael drews
der immer lockerer geworden vor jeder
szene irgendwie war oh gott was tut mir
so leid und hinterher
ach so es war richtig zu beginnen so
dass ihr euch so lange denn ich hab dann
will ich hatte mich schon wieder
anschreien tut mir so leid okay aber mit
der zeit wäre dann mehr eingespielt
haben euren rollen und dann habt ihr
euch wirklich so verhalten wie tante und
falls ihr noch mehr aber tanz marianne
wissen wollte habe ich euch auch noch
einen link und in die video beschreibung
gepackt über den ihr weiteres über
marianne erfahrt also das was erstmal
von meinen fragen an dich dominique dann
habe ich noch auf instagram alle
zuschauer gefragt ob die noch fragen
dich herunterkam ein enormer andrang
mit tausenden zehntausenden fragen ich
fange jetzt mal direkt damit der ersten
frage von einem user namens happy locker
waren die ihr manche szenen unangenehmen
ein unangenehm nicht dann hätte ich
nicht gemacht
das komische stadt zustehenden mit
irgendwelchen klamotten leute die gucken
aber man hat eine kamera dabei also die
leute wissen eigentlich also bist du im
privaten leben auch immer so viele
süßigkeiten die hab ich auch im privaten
leben während der drehzeit nicht
wirklich gelten klar jeder ist mal
schokolade chips also ich bin halt
wirklich eher der chipstüte durch den
magen bypasses nie schon gar nicht
möglich irgendwie möglichkeiten
einzuschreiten also du bist jetzt nicht
so dass du den ganzen tag so was ja
einige wirklich diese absurde
vorstellung haben dass du den ganzen tag
hier sitzt und süßigkeiten isst und dann
ab und zu mal ein salat nur aus fleisch
wurst und käse besteht also man sieht
sie auch sonst wäre die verwandlung sage
ich mal nicht möglich gewesen hätte ich
auch keine polizei abgenommen weil auch
mit dem magen bypasses ist kein machen
ja kein wirklich drauf hast du deine
folgende ab und zu selbst kann und ich
habe wirklich noch nie eine folge im
fernsehen gesehen ich war dabei muss
war es schwer beim spielen der rolle
nicht selbst lassen zu müssen
es war wirklich anstrengend die szenen
so durchzuziehen
danach war eigentlich erst mal nach
deutschland sagt wir mussten einiges
auch ein paar mal ansetzen weil es ging
einfach nicht dann habe ich tatsächlich
jetzt auch schon die letzte frage die
wir von einem zuschauer gestellt wurde
und zwar schlicht weg wie geht es dir
gerade ja also mir geht es gut ich
gesagt schon alleine durch die abnahme
hat sich halt hier getan ich bin
unternehmungslustiger man geht halt
gerne raus man kann ich halt auch
bewegen gerade jetzt mit den kindern bin
jetzt gerade halt den elternteil es ist
wirklich festzustellen das ist ja auch
nichts was jetzt irgendwie du sagst und
mich besser zu fühlen sondern das sieht
ja jeder auch gerade es gibt einmal
doppel die gespielte rolle die vor
wirklich was war das acht jahren glaube
ja vor acht jahren das muss man sich mal
vorstellen
die folgen werden jetzt gerade
hochgeladen leute denken echt hält sieht
jetzt gerade so aus aber es ist so wie
gregory ein komplett neuer mensch du
hast auch schon nicht komplett vermeiden
dass es noch mal
ins tv für dich gehen wird werden dann
aber natürlich unter anderen umständen
dass der auch schon gesagt aber mehr
wollen wir dazu jetzt gar nicht sagen
ich möchte mich an der stelle auf jeden
fall schon mal bei dir bedanken hier das
duo offen ist und dass wir dieses
interview führen dürfen weil man da
jetzt eigentlich gelungener abschluss
sagen ich mache diese ganze serie ist
mittlerweile glaube ich acht oder neun
reactions auf handys sowie videos
hochgeladen es war mir selbst auch
wichtig in den folgen oft zu sagen hey
die rolle auf die krise reagiere ist
eine gespielte rolle es geht nicht gegen
die person dahinter nicht kaputtgemacht
solltest du auch mal haben jetzt ganz
ganz lange geredet noch mal danke danke
danke dass sie uns hier auch so viele
sachen und gesagt hast wie es wirklich
hinter den kulissen abliefen ihr könnt
mir auch mal die kommentare schreiben
hättet ihr gedacht dass tante marianne
gar nicht die richtige taste ist hättet
ihr gedacht dass die schauspielerin
doppel in der rutsche stecken geblieben
ist oder hättet ihr auch gedacht dass
der roller angesägt wurde treibt mir das
gerne in die kommentare lassen einen
daumen hoch bei den video da wird euch
dieses interview hier gefallen hat schon
gern bei der dominik vorbei auf ihrem
facebook profil also alles ist unter der
beschreibung verlinkt und wir
verabschieden
[Musik]